non
[Musique]
le
pour tout vous dire la vie d'un pêcheur
c'est une belle vie le pêcheur c'est un
privilégié
on se nourrit de ce qu'il ya dans l'eau
on vit à côté de la plage on s'y baigne
on a cette vue merveilleuse
on est en contact avec cet air pur du
matin est en osmose avec environnement
son sommes les fils des cayes cajas les
petits enfants d'indigènes qui
habitaient la baie de guanabara
il faut respecter notre habitat c'est ça
notre rêve
une baie de guanabara scène pour que nos
fils et nos petits enfants puissent en
profiter et qu'il puisse devenir pêcheur
comme nous
[Musique]
la baie de guanabara possède encore
beaucoup de richesses il ya beaucoup
d'eau propre qui vient des montagnes
mais aujourd'hui nous vivons l'enfer de
l'industrialisation le pétrole les
usines autour de la baie de guanabara et
tous les jours on voit les problèmes
s'aggravent et l'écologie la biologie de
la baie a changé nous sommes les
premiers affectés et en même temps nous
sommes les gardiens les surveillants de
cette nature tous les jours on prend le
pouls de la baie de guanabara comme ça
et après tu le tiens de côté avant cinq
minutes il y avait des poissons on
utilise beaucoup beaucoup de filet on va
blement 2000 mètres pour pêcher une
seule boîte de poissons maximum notre
paradis est en train de disparaître
et si nous ne faisons rien il risque de
se transformer en enfer d'ici 50 ans il
pourrait ne plus y avoir de pêche ici à
kemal
[Musique]
j'ai l'honneur d'annoncer que les 31e
jeux olympiques sont attribués à rio de
janeiro 2 octobre 2009 la ville de rio
obtient l'organisation des jeux
olympiques d'été pour 2016
une reconnaissance une vitrine pour le
brésil est encore plus pour la capitale
touristique du pays
riou son christ rédempteur son pain de
sucre ses plages d'ipanema et copacabana
mondialement connu des cartes postales
où tout le monde
les athlètes en premier rêve un jour de
se rendre une bonne partie des épreuves
aquatiques se dérouleront dans la baie
de guanabara au nord-est de la ville l'a
encore vu du ciel
le lieu est enchanteur mais l'envers du
décor l'est beaucoup moins
la baie est jonchée de déchets et nombre
de ses rives sont devenus des dépotoirs
certains égouts s'y déversent
directement et plusieurs plages sur
devenu à propre à la baignade
malgré les promesses des politiques en
vue des jo saxton ici c'est censé être
la carte postale de rio vous y croyez
vous oui j ou si c'est une blague
en trente ans la mère est aussi devenu
l'arrière-cour de l'exploitation des
champs pétroliers au large de rio des
raffineries des tankers des plateformes
et les catastrophes environnementales
qui vont avec
marée noire fuite de produits chimiques
et autres polluants déversés par les
industriels en toute impunité
habitant écologistes pêcheurs dénoncent
depuis des années une catastrophe
annoncée
parfois au risque de leur vie
après tout ces attentats j'ai eu très
peur mais maintenant je ne crains plus
de mourir si un jour je ne suis plus là
je crains plutôt pour ma famille mes
enfants et mes amis
[Musique]
à la rencontre de ceux qui se battent
pour sauver guanabara enquête au coeur
de la baie des cauchemars
[Musique]
9 mars dernier au petit matin aux abords
de l'aéroport international dans la baie
de guanabara un drôle de bateau poubelle
entame déjà sa deuxième tournée il ya
des jours où le bateau est remplie
jusqu'ici on peut à peine se déplacer
après on doit tout décharger dans les
conteneurs et si on a le temps on
retourne dans la baie et on recommence
c'est notre routine dit yao était bauer
marins depuis janvier 2014
il travaille dans le cadre du programme
eco boat
comme lui une dizaine de salariés
tentent tous les jours de nettoyer la
baie devenue bien malgré elle la
décharge de rio et même pire de lille on
a déjà trouvé un cadavre des corps
criblés de balles qu'on a balancé dans
l'eau on trouve tous des animaux des
frigos des fumées des micro-ondes des
lave-linge de tours
parfois on voit les passagers des
ferries jeter leur gobelet dans la mer
si les gens avaient vraiment conscience
des conséquences
cette baisse serait beaucoup plus propre
et facile à nettoyer
après tout on travaille pour le futur de
nos enfants et de nos petits enfants
trois bateaux à l'origine puis 6 puis 10
et récemment une flottille de bateaux
plus petits est venu compléter le
dispositif est un travail d équipe
quand ils voient beaucoup d'ordures ils
nous appellent pour qu on leur file un
coup de main
et quand c'est nous qui voyons des
ordures par exemple des détritus
éparpillés sur les rochers on les
appelle pour qu'ils nous aident avec
leurs bateaux qui sont plus petits et
dix bateaux ce n'est pas un peu juste
pour tout nettoyer
si c'est impossible pour bien travailler
il nous en faudrait encore deux ou trois
minimum sauf que pour ça on a besoin
d'argent et ça devient difficile
depuis quelques semaines déjà sonné même
plus payer mais il dira de la foi vous
voyez ça c'est déjà un salaire c'est
notre récompense les gens admirent notre
travail
il trouve ça génial parfois ils nous
soutiennent et nous interpelle
félicitations grâce à vie la berre
redevient belle est ce que la baisse
sera propre pour les jeux oui je pense
que c'est possible on peut tout nettoyer
avant les jeux olympiques
et tout le monde pourra nager autant
qu'il le voudra
pour la baignade il faudra attendre le 3
avril dernier le projet ekobo de juger
inefficace par le ministère de
l'environnement a été suspendu
dia ho et ses amis avaient malgré tout
retirer de la mais pour la seule année
430 tonnes de déchets les autorités ont
préféré l'option des échos barrière à
l'embouchure des rivières
elle bloque et détritus avant qu'il
n'arrive dans la benne une solution
encore loin d'être idéales
[Musique]
pour ceux qui vivent la baie au
quotidien le constat est toujours aussi
amère et l'inquiétude grandissante
martin et sa soeur kahena sont
championnes du monde en forte in einer
une des disciplines de la voile
olympique
elles défendent les couleurs du brésil
pour elle la pollution de la baie
représente un danger pour les athlètes
qui régatent ici
je suis venu de l'autre côté de la baie
en bateau et j'ai dû contourner
plusieurs fois les déchets les déchets
flottants un danger est aussi le risque
de fausser la compétition
je pense que le plus gênant ce sont les
sacs plastiques parce qu'on ne les voit
pas et les objets qui flotte juste
dessous du niveau de l'eau car l'eau est
sale parce qu'il reste coincé sur la
dérive et ça peut renverser l'abîmé le
battait et nous on risque de se faire
mal on naviguait est en pleine régate un
sac plastique s'est coincé dans le
gouvernail ça nous a beaucoup perturbé
martine et moi on n'arrivait pas à
l'atteindre le bateau allait trop vite
impossible à attraper
on n'arrivait pas enlever le sac donc il
est resté là jusqu'à la fin de la course
c'est horrible quand ça arrive en
compétition car on perd beaucoup de
vitesse et les autres bateaux vous
dépasse sa diatribe à ses passes
pour quelques temps les oncles de martin
nous ont raconté comment s'étaient avoir
il prenait un bateau et il allait là-bas
à pêcher plongée passer un week end
aujourd'hui c'est impossible on peut
même plus rentrer dans l'eau une
situation connue aujourd'hui du monde
entier
récemment en asie un petit film
d'animation satirique pour dénoncer
cette extrême pollution a fait le buzz
sur le web les médias taïwanais ont
diffusé une vidéo
les athlètes montent sur le podium ils
reçoivent leurs médailles et commence à
vomir et à déféquer
ou alors ils sont en train de ramer mais
ils perdent les rames dans l'eau sale et
il se met à ramer avec les mains ce sont
des choses absurdes mais en réalité ça
pourrait bien nous arriver
[Musique]
et là par exemple il ya un poisson mort
ça vous paraît normal c'est normal
malheureusement ce n'est pas normal mais
ici à la baie de guanabara
on voit ça souvent malheureusement on
voit ça tous les jours je vais être à
votre avis qui polluent le plus à gwadar
à tout le monde le fait un peu on ne
peut pas accuser quelqu'un en
particulier
vous pensez que les égouts de ces
maisons sont évacués où on n'a pas
d'assainissement ici on ne peut pas dire
que les gens des favelas ce sens ce qui
polluent le plus et moi je dois évoluer
le bâtiment où je vis déverse peut-être
ses égouts ici oui c'est notre faute à
moi à martin amis la propreté de la baie
cela commence avec l'éducation et les
infrastructures
tant qu'on a pas ça tu ne peux pas la
garder propre ego mal raccordé
population peu sensibilisés à l'écologie
et infrastructures défaillantes
la liste des maux qui affectent la belle
et longue
[Musique]
riou s'étend sur une superficie dix fois
supérieure à celle de paris et compte
plus de 6 millions d'habitants pour se
rendre compte de l'ampleur des problèmes
il faut prendre un peu de hauteur mario
moscatelli est un biologiste connue et
reconnue au brésil
régulièrement ils tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé pour alerter l'opinion publique
ça fait 20 ans que je survole la ville
de rio de janeiro et que je la prends en
photo pour dénoncer je voudrais montrer
à tous comment la baisse se dégrade
malheureusement ça ne sert pas à grand
chose
[Musique]
la détérioration est de plus en plus
grande ce que dénonce mario moscatelli
c'est l'urbanisation anarchique et
continue de la ville notamment à travers
ses favelas
regardez juste en dessous il y a les
jardins gramacho ce ce sont des
dépotoirs clandestins
on jette tout là dedans sans aucun
contrôle
ça contamine le sol toute cette zone va
probablement se transformer en une
nouvelle favelas regarder tout ça ce
sont des dépotoirs des dépotoirs
clandestins personne ne les contrôle les
pouvoirs publics n'ont plus aucune
emprise ici
favelas dépotoir déchets ménagers
rejeter directement dans la baie une
pollution visible de tous au sol comme
en l'air mais pas forcément la plus
préoccupante
regardez tout est pourri à cause des
égouts et des ordures c'est quoi cette
couleur dans l'eau c'est de l'eau
polluée
non traitée chargée en métaux lourds
regarder la couleur de l'eau sur la
lagune de jacarapagua cette eau verte
que l'on voit dans les lagunes
c'est dû aux cyanobactéries elles
viennent de la pollution des égouts
regardez-la au croisement des deux
canaux c'est de l'eau pourrie de l'eau
pourrie qui nourrit les cyanobactéries
certaines espèces de ces micro
organismes peuvent donner le cancer
ces fleuves sont complètement pourri à
l'origine de cette pollution
bactériologique toujours cette
urbanisation non contrôlée et des
infrastructures de traitement des eaux
qui n'ont pas suivi
regardez ça c'est absurde c'est la
station d'épuration d'alegria elle ne
fonctionne qu'à 50%
quel est le problème avec cette station
ils n'ont pas posé les canalisations
entre la station et les quartiers les
plus pauvres
[Musique]
ce qu'on nous avait promis l'engagement
écologique pour les jo c'était bien
différent c'était la restauration de
toute la baie bien sûr cette
restauration c'était important pour les
jo mais surtout c'était primordial pour
les cariocas
mais ils n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses
[Musique]
la ville se modernise d'accord mais les
problèmes restent toujours les mêmes
des problèmes qui s'étendent depuis
plusieurs années la pollution n'est plus
cantonné à la baie de guanabara
même les belles plages de rio les plages
touristiques comme copacabana ipanema
houbara sont parfois touché
à chaque marée toute la contamination de
la lagune va jusqu'aux plages de barra
ça veut dire que c'est polluer jusqu'ici
exactement toute l'année et jusqu'à
l'autre bout de la plage n'ont pas
complètement ça dépend de la météo
un océan de polluants des rives de la
baie transformé en décharge et des
autorités publiques indifférente la
situation empire d'année en année à rio
[Musique]
de retour au sol marco moscatelli tient
à nous montrer en quoi les politiques
publiques en matière d'environnement
sont aberrants ce nous sommes sur les
berges du canal du fondo l'autre côté se
trouvent les chantiers navals
c'est l'un des lieux les plus contaminés
de la baie de guanabara
mais grâce au travail qu'on a réalisé il
ya trois ans a pu restaurer ce pas d'y
construire
cris a espéré y en a tous les ans ici la
nature a besoin de très peu pour
renaître ray coupé à la poker ça a coûté
beaucoup d'argent parce que c'était un
projet de revitalisation du canal de
forme d'un projet c'était un projet du
secrétariat pour l'environnement mise en
marche par le gouvernement précédent
il ya patch qui cohabitent on a fait un
dragage de ce canal et j'ai dirigé la
restauration des berges pas obstacle
tout ça ce n'était que de la boue et des
déchets pour le transformer liche
on a dû modifier les lieux la
topographie la hauteur de la zone et
ensuite on a replanté la main et plantes
à kong
ici il ya une couche de végétation qui
forme une barrière mais regardez ces
déchets
[Musique]
tout ça avant c'était propre en 2012
tout était parfaitement pro belge et
salons projet malheureusement ça a été
pris en charge par le secrétariat pour
l'environnement et bien qu'il ait été
prévenu plusieurs fois qu'il fallait
préserver la zone
le secrétaire a fait la sourde oreille
et tout le travail fait jusque là
tout l'argent public investi a été jeté
à la poubelle
giniel au public ça c'est la réalité du
développement durable quand les caméras
ne sont pas là on peut parcourir le
canal du film d'amour pendant des
kilomètres
on ne verra que ça que cette dégradation
c'est comme ça la gestion publique au
brésil on investit beaucoup d'argent
pour la restauration d'un espace maison
ne fait aucune maintenance et on revient
à la case départ c'est de l'argent
public jeté à la poubelle c'est rio de
janeiro voici l'entrée international de
rio de janeiro la ville olympique
à quatre mois des jo regardez l'état
cette ville ne pourrait même pas
accueillir une fête de fin d'année
cette région elle résume bien le drame
de la baie de guanabara
on peut voir la croissance chaotique
l'absence de politique publique de
logement
l'occupation désordonnée des bassins
versants à occupation et rivière sont
transformées en décharges où se
déversent les égouts ou ce format et
toutes ces ordures circulent par les
canaux et arrive jusqu'à la baie de
guanabara prochain à nice il travaillait
de le problème de la baie n'est plus
environnementale il est criminel et
quasi du pulis lanceur d'alert mario
moscatelli a plusieurs fois été menacé
de mort mais il continue son combat
à 20 km de là sur la rive opposée en
amont de la rivière macaques ou le
village de pêcheurs de tombo
[Musique]
en pleine zone protégée la petite
communauté et pourtant touchée elle
aussi par la pollution de la bête
dans certains comtés c'est un lot a fait
gallas lambret l'intéressé en cours de
groupe et aux plages bahianais rap et au
bras le pétrole est là bas au fond et il
continue de tuer tout le monde sait que
dans la mer on ne trouve plus de tam
homme est un nid de bagré jaune
il n'y a plus de crever de cette année
ni de pirates
les poissons disparaissent
jadis on pouvait offrir des palombes et
à nos amis de nombreuses espèces ont
disparu
alexandre anderson dea souza et
président de la omar une association de
défense des pêcheurs de la baie il est
venu aujourd'hui chercher l'adhésion de
nouveaux membres
vous êtes la résistance tant que vous
aurez le courage de garder votre mode de
vie ici vous nous aidez nous qui
habitons dans la baie car la seule
source d'eau propre qui arrive à la baie
de guanabara
c'est celle qui vient d'ici de la
rivière macacos et c'est grâce à vous
car quand vous partirez cet endroit
deviendra une plateforme pétrolière
une raffinerie nous sommes ensemble dans
cette lutte
sa cible principale le géant pétrolier a
cessé ses activités au coeur de la baie
de guanabara
avec ses 14 plateformes pétrolières
ces deux ports commerciaux ces deux
raffineries et les dizaines de bateaux
qui travaillent en permanence pour son
compte
petrobras est de fait un des plus gros
pollueurs de la baie
18 janvier 2000 la rupture d'un oléoduc
de la compagnie nationale provoque l'un
des plus graves accidents
environnementale d'amérique latine le
conduit percé vomi 1,3 million de litres
de pétrole
vingt mille pêcheurs sont touchés
pendant de nombreux mois
seize ans plus tard presque aucun
d'entre eux n'a été indemnisé depuis
d'autres catastrophes ont meurtri la
baie toujours sans dédommagement à qui
j'ai dans mes mains le jugement dans son
intégralité
je vais vous lire la première partie le
27 avril 2009 était confirmé
l'installation du gazoduc provoquant
l'impossibilité de l'activité
poissonnière dans la région nous
demandons à petrobras solidairement est
âgé des cas et l'océanic qui les
indemnise les 96 pêcheurs impactés par
ces installations de trois fois le
salaire minimum pendant 18 mois
ça fait un peu plus de 42 mille real
chacun les juges se sont prononcés en
notre faveur c'est le verdict final ils
vont l'exécuter cette année ça a
commencé par une simple action civile de
96 pêcheurs mais maintenant tous les
associés de la omar peuvent en
bénéficier
et la preuve est ici voici la référence
de la faire c'est une action collective
de la omar on peut vous inclure car nous
aussi
vous avez été touchés convaincre unir
fédérer les pêcheurs contre petrobras le
combat d'une vie pour alexandre un
combat commencé il ya de nombreuses
années déjà être embrasse quitter la
baie de guanabara laisser vivre la baie
de guanabara au 2012 alexandre et ses
amis pêcheurs manifestent devant les
locaux de petrobras au coeur du quartier
des affaires de rio pêcheurs et xix
jamais ne sera vaincu pêcheurs uni
jamais ne sera vaincu
aujourd'hui nous montrons au monde que
ces actes criminels sont commis depuis
des années sur la baie de guanabara qu
ils doivent être traduits en justice est
sorti de notre zone de pêche l'impunité
c'est ce que dénoncent les manifestants
la fin de leur mode de vie aussi est ce
qu'un jour on aura la paix est ce qu'un
jour on sera enfin tranquille pour
pouvoir rentrer chez nous avec dignité
celle d'exercer notre fonction de
pêcheurs artisans petrobras va devoir
nous entendre
les pêcheurs ont le droit d'exister ce
jour là malgré leur nombre
les pêcheurs ne seront pas reçus comme
d'habitude
son engagement son activisme
l'association à omar l'a déjà payé très
cher face aux zone interdite à la pêche
qui se sont multipliés ces dernières
années
ces militants ont de nombreuses fois
manifesté sur les sites et demander des
compensations financières pour la baisse
de leur activité
quelques victoires à la clé devant la
justice mais aussi de lourdes défaites
menacé plusieurs pêcheurs ont même été
assassinés comme paulo cesar santos
souza en 2009
admire nogueira amorim en 2012 ou encore
luis telesp et naîtra la même année
[Musique]
les meurtriers n'ont jamais été
identifiés les commanditaires jamais
inquiété à ce jour aucune charge contre
petrobras ou ses sous traitants n'a été
retenue dans ses affaires
nous retrouvons alexandre chez lui pour
sa sécurité
nous ne vous montreront pas l'extérieur
de son immeuble le pêcheur militants lui
aussi a plusieurs fois été menacé de
mort il a même par moments bénéficier
d'une protection policière
contraint de déménager souvent lui et sa
famille mène depuis plusieurs années une
vie de fugitif une cavale force est
difficile à supporter pour sa femme
nous avons très mal vécu cette épreuve
ce qui est marrant c'est que nous
défendions les autres et que nous étions
considérés comme des criminels
[Musique]
c'est comme si c'était nous qui
attaquent sion les pêcheurs alors qu'au
contraire c'était petrobras toutes les
semaines tous les week-ends nous étions
obligés de prendre l'avion pour brasilia
cacher ne pouvions pas passer le week
end avec nos enfants à la maison avec
nos petits enfants
je n'ai commencé à le voir vraiment
cassé trois ans j'ai enfin pu m'occuper
davantage de lui jouer un rôle de grand
mère au qatar avant je ne pouvais pas
notre vie était une course c'est
vraiment très dur
je n'aime pas parler de ça ça me fait
pleurer pour oublier leurs larmes
alexandre et daid tiennent à nous
montrer ce qui les fait encore tenait
dans cette lutte nous avons obtenu
beaucoup de reconnaissance la plus
importante c'est celle de la communauté
nous avons reçu des médailles à la
médaille chico mendes s'est écrit
là-dessus torture plus jamais gloire aux
héros de la lutte pour la vie et de la
dignité de l'homme
nous avons reçu un prix national pour la
défense des droits de l'homme à qui là
nous sommes dans une conférence sur les
droits de l'homme j'ai participé à la
table aux côtés des indigènes et
d'autres personnes dans la lutte
nous avons beaucoup de travail dans
toutes nos réunions nous arrivons à
mobiliser beaucoup de pêcheurs
nous tenons des rapports voilà par
exemple une réunion que nous avons fait
contre petrobras regardez tous les
pêcheurs qui étaient présents des
réunions des manifestations des diplômes
et des médailles mais rien n'y a fait
l'industrialisation et la pollution de
la baie de guanabara n'ont jamais cessé
aller allons-y la part is in ce matin
malgré le danger
alexandre nous emmène au coeur de la
baie pour nous montrer l'ampleur du
problème
ici c'est le terminal de l'île ago c'est
ici qu'il y a eu la fuite de pétrole qui
a pollué la baie de guanabara en 2001
regardez la quantité deux conduits qui
descendent dans l'eau
on ne peut pas rester longtemps ici là
bas c'est un autre terminal de carburant
terminal de petrobras terminal de
petrobras et terminale de petrobras
ils occupent toutes les îles et les eaux
de la baie de guanabara
vous voyez il ya des fuites c'est pour
ça qu'il y à des bouées les fuites sont
constantes les conduit son vieux est
défectueuse
depuis des années l'or noir trouvait au
large de rio fait l'objet de toutes les
convoitises plateforme raffineries et
bateaux ont poussé comme des champignons
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans le coin il doit y avoir
soit 110 à 80 embarcations comme celle
ci sans compter les navires juste des
remorqueurs utilisé par les pétroliers
cet énorme dans un si petit espace 1
aujourd'hui la baisse s'est transformée
en base arrière des champs
d'exploitation une zone sous haute
tension
[Musique]
en nous suit là je pense qu'on nous suit
il n'aime pas les tournages
en effet il n'aime pas ça la nuit c'est
encore pire si quelqu'un vient les
observer et filmer les crimes qu'ils
commettent parce qu'ils ne devraient pas
travailler la nuit ils envoient leurs
agents de sécurité
la nuit ils peuvent être très violents
ce que petrobras et ses sous-traitants
veulent cacher les dégâts
environnementaux quotidien qui causent
au milieu marin fuite d'hydrocarbures
rejets de produits chimiques
le tout directement dans les eaux de la
baie sans traitement
là ce que nous voyons c'est du
dégraissant un produit sa venue qui fait
de la mousse ça met longtemps à se
dissoudre
il n'y a pas eu de vent donc ça ne peut
pas venir de l'agitation des eaux
c'est bien du dégraissant il utilise
dans les remorqueurs lorsqu ils
nettoient les cales
c'est interdit par la loi certains
produits chimiques déversés dans la
nature
je ne pense pas que ce soit très sûr de
faire ça regardez regardez moi ça se
produit savonneux je ne sais même pas si
on a le droit de faire ça si ce n'est
pas dangereux ça une odeur
parfois ils ont des pénalités ils sont
identifiés mais il n'y a pas vraiment de
volonté des services publics de résoudre
la question
regardez ça colle un peu regardé cette
couleur
[Musique]
cet endroit c'était une île merveilleuse
la construction est récente ça a
commencé en 2009 celle ci c'est lille
conflit de regarder la couleur du
liquide qui sort des tuyaux et l'odeur
que ça a c'est plein de produits
chimiques
c'est à la même hauteur que la mousse
que nous avons traversé tout à l'heure
si l'inspection vient les voir ils leur
diront qu'il s'agit de l'eau des pluies
ou de l'échappement des gaz de
refroidissement mais santé cette odeur
ce sont les dégraissant qu'ils utilisent
un non-respect de la loi très rarement
sanctionnés de quoi écoeurer alexandre
il n'y a pas de contrôle où est la
police fédérale et les services de
sécurité publique corruption collusion
arrangements entre amis
alexandre a souvent dénoncé cette
réalité quotidienne au brésil peine
perdue aujourd'hui encore les autorités
continuent d'afficher leur optimisme on
est content pour l'instant ils disent
que c'est une baie de guanabara
olympique
on voit déjà que ce ne sera pas si
olympique donc après les jeux elle va
devenir quoi cette vert on parlera
encore d'une belle ou alors simplement
d'une zone portuaire pour les pétroliers
gigantesque port pour l'industrie
pétrolière
la bête possède pourtant encore quelques
trésors
[Musique]
nous sommes avec josé leon brito
océanographe et professeur à
l'université de rio
là on s'approche de la zone la mieux
préservée de la baie de guanabara
c'est le secteur nord-est de l'île de
pâques et à jusqu'à la baie de bois pvc
la zone protégée la plus importante de
la baie de guanabara
il y a des marsouins autour de nous et
jusqu'au fond de la baie c'est là où il
y en a le plus on va essayer de se
rapprocher
le dauphin l'emblème même de rio un
résident permanent qui voit son habitat
son lieu de vie rétrécir chaque année
comme peau de chagrin
j'ai aujourd'hui les animaux se sont
réfugiées ici dans cette zone de
protection environnementale de groupies
mirim par rapport aux autres c'est la
zone qui a subi le moins de dégâts dans
toute la baie mais ce petit paradis est
aujourd'hui menacé même ici les bateaux
liés à l'industrie pétrolière commence à
grignoter la zone
la société dow cash qui gère l'ancrage
sur la baie de guanabara proposer un
élargissement de cette zone
contrairement à toutes nos
revendications ils ont proposé une
extension de la zone d'ancrage jusqu'au
fond de la baie pour nous cette
proposition est totalement inacceptable
aujourd'hui où je navigue fondu à des
jeux tant par les navires ne bouge pas
mais ils émettent du sont contents qu'on
agite chiche quand on plonge un hydro
microphone sous l'eau on entend le bruit
qu'ils produisent ou tomba à genoux mais
qd à son film ici dans la baie par
exemple l'eau n'est pas très
transparente à cause de ça
sous l'eau les dauphins voit mal ce
qu'il ya autour d'eux comment voulez
vous qu'ils se déplacent ou somalie mais
comment font-ils pour chasser comment
cherche-t-il leur nourriture du vivre
comment communique les mères et leur
petit et les couples entre eux cameroun
sont normalement ça se fait par le son
donc n'importe quel interférences
acoustique n'importe quelle pollution
sonore sous l'eau vale perturber les
marsouins sont au sommet de la chaîne
alimentaire de la baie de guanabara les
animaux en tête de la chaîne
ne survivent que si leur environnement
est sain il ya un grand risque de
disparition si on ne fait rien si on ne
change pas notre façon d'occuper la baie
cette population a peu de chances de
pouvoir résister sans combats et des
chiens
la pollution sonore un ennemi invisible
mais redoutable pour les d'haufor
[Musique]
oui
de retour au laboratoire lisbeth en
cours membre de l'équipe de josé analyse
les enregistrements sonores qu'elles
réalisent régulièrement dans son
ordinateur
la mémoire acoustique de la baie depuis
dix ans
ses lignes sont le signalement des
colocations des mares sont comme des
ennemis quand ils émettent un ultrason
il attendre que les cours reviennent à
eux pour localiser leur nourriture
je suis en train de vous sélectionné
trois types d'enregistrements de deux
régions différentes de la baie de
guanabara lci toc toc c'est ce toc toc
que vous entendez ce sont des bruits de
poissons l'environnement naturel c'est
ça des bruits d'animaux le mouvement de
l'eau on a hésité quand on écoute un son
tout provient d'une zone remplie d'un
navire russe vous allez voir que c'est
beaucoup plus fort le bruit est bien
pire
imaginez un email
suivie dans une zone aussi bruyante et
on entend cela 24 heures sur 24
whitacre a dit m
une forte concentration de bruit sous
aquatique ne va pas tuer les animaux
elle n'a pas d'impact direct sur sa
cause des problèmes de stress
ça réduit la capacité du système
immunitaire de ces animaux danger réel
pour les dauphins ce constat raphaël
ramos le fait depuis de nombreuses
années déjà
biologiste à l'université de rio il
répertorie les mammifères de la baie
grâce à un catalogue photographique
riche de milliers de clichés qu'on peut
observer que cet animal à différentes
marques tout le long de sa nageoire
elles sont apparues avec le temps à
cause des interactions avec les autres
animaux et avec son environnement
cela nous serve d'empreintes digitales
pour reconnaître chacun de ces animaux
avec cet outil à long terme on arrive à
déterminer la taille de cette population
c'est grâce à cette technique
d'identification photographique que l'on
arrive à savoir que la population des
marsouins de la baie de guanabara et de
37 animaux des années 80 à aujourd'hui
on est passé d'une population d'environ
quatre cents à 37 animaux c'est une
réduction de 90% de la population en
presque trente ans les deux fins qui
naissent ne survivent pas et quelques
adultes qui sont la visite ici depuis 20
ans et même plus on s'en est rendu
compte grâce à notre technique
d'identification photographique mais on
voit que parmi les animaux qui naissent
il y en a plein qui n'atteignent pas
l'âge de se reproduire ça brise
complètement le cycle dans 10 ou 15 ans
si l'on continue sur ce rythme on finira
par perdre toute la population
la santé la baie de guanabara poubelles
de rio deviendra-t-elle bientôt son
cimetière
[Musique]
mario moscatelli est convaincu que la
fin est proche régulièrement ils
alertent l'opinion pour réveiller les
consciences avec un goût très prononcé
pour la mise en scène
aujourd'hui direction la plage de
botafogo juste en face du pain de sucre
[Musique]
bon
je me demande pourquoi les gens ont si
peur des cercueils passion du foot
[Musique]
il pose le ici maintenant on va chercher
la banderole et
[Musique]
pour nous y habitons ici c'est une honte
ce matin mario moscatelli a convoqué la
presse pour un enterrement symbolique de
la veille des années qu'ils dénoncent
une situation aujourd'hui sur le point
de non retour
c'est une plage considérer impropre à la
baignade tout là l'une des cartes
postales de rio de janeiro a été
transformé en toilettes publiques et ça
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui duduche qu'a
duré ce sont des décennies de négligence
d'un manque de responsabilité d'impunité
de malversations et notre illusion
c'était les jo il fallait ce match
malheureusement ce n'est pas encore
aujourd'hui qu'on la verra propre et
vous seriez prêt la sphère du paddle
jamais de la vie
vous allez voir les amis que je vais
enfiler pour mettre les pieds là dedans
on prend aucun risque
celui qui rentre dans l'eau risque de
choper une gastro une otite une
conjonctivite ou même une hépatite et on
met pas cheap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tampa des dates brasse de l'air les
autorités gouvernementales savait elle
était au courant pour la baie de
guanabara la balle il avait promis
d'agir pour l'environnement mais ils
n'ont rien fait voici le résultat
quelle honte à toi la baie de guanabara
cherbet je te demande pardon pour moi
pour ma famille et pour mes amis nous
sommes tous ici remplis de regrets en
tant que biologiste et citoyens de rio
de janeiro
je prie pour le salut de la crique de
botafogo assassiné jour après jour
mutilé par l'incompétence par l'impunité
par les malversations au des pouvoirs
publics brésiliens et par l'apathie et
la passivité de son peuple
le jour où je te verrai propres je suis
sûr que je ne serai plus sur terre je
serai dans un lieu où la plupart des
politiciens ne rentreront jamais un cri
une colère afin de provoquer un ultime
sursaut politique et citoyen pour sauver
cette plage vitrine du pays aux yeux du
monde entier
[Musique]
rio ville olympique au fécales ce sont
les premières olympiades fécales
postmoderne mario le sait son appel a
peu de chances d'être entendus
reste alors la pédagogie envers les plus
jeunes tu vois petit ce n'est pas
possible de se baigner paris s'y voit le
trou il y à du caca qui sort sans arrêt
alors si tu rentres dans cette eau tu as
déjà eu mal au ventre et bien là tu
auras plus mal au ventre que tu n'as
jamais eu de toute ta vient donc tu ne
peux pas te baigner c'est vraiment
dommage ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
la baie de guanabara
c'est du terrorisme environnemental
d'état foursac et les pouvoirs publics
qui devraient être en train de protéger
les ressources naturelles parce qu'ils
sont payés pour ça
sont en train de les détruire ça c'est
du terrorisme du terrorisme
environnemental d'état des mots
provocateurs très fort très dur mais une
situation effectivement proche de la
catastrophe
malgré nos demandes répétées pendant des
mois ni petrobras ni la municipalité de
rioz ni le gouvernement n'ont accepté de
répondre à nos questions
aujourd'hui la situation de la berre est
sous-estimée d'autant que la pollution
la plus dangereuse n'est pas forcément
la plus visible
dans ce laboratoire de microbiologie on
cultive des bactéries pour mieux les
étudier des recherches indispensable
pour trouver les futurs romed à des
souches devenues résistantes aux
antibiotiques
surprise ou pas certaines d'entre elles
ont été trouvées dans la baie de
guanabara
[Musique]
face à une bactérie comme celle ci
résistante à plusieurs types
d'antibiotiques et que les médecins ne
sont pas en mesure de traiter la plupart
des patients vont sûrement mourir
les personnes âgées les enfants les
personnes avec immunodéficience ne
résisteront pas parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'antibiotiques pour les traiter ces
bactéries n'appartiennent pas à la baie
de guanabara
elle ne devrait pas être là elles ne
font pas partie de la faune de la baie
elles ont été amenées là bas il faut que
l'on creuse cette question pour savoir
comment elles sont arrivés là ces
bactéries proviennent d'un hôpital
c'est très étonnant elles sont aussi
présentes dans lens de botafogo et dans
la marina de la gloria elles peuvent
être dans n'importe quelle plage de rio
oui c'est possible si elles ont été
retrouvées dans lens de bluff au go et
dans la marina da gloria c'est qu'elles
sont dans la barque et si elles sont
dans la belle n'importe quel courant
d'eau peut les amener sur la plage
cette inquiétude provient d'un rapport
sortie en 2013
une étude conservait précieusement ici
d'autant qu'elle s'avère impossible à
trouver aujourd'hui sur le net
impossible aussi de rentrer en contact
avec les deux scientifiques qui l'ont
mené des bactéries dangereuses pour la
santé qui infestent la baie pour
beaucoup ici les autorités ont voulu
étouffer la faire je ne peux pas
l'affirmer parce que pour l'instant je
n'ai pas de preuve mais je pense que ces
bactéries viennent des égouts les
travaux de mario moscatelli l'ont déjà
plusieurs fois pouvait imaginer ça à
botafogo vont se dérouler plusieurs
épreuves olympiques avec des athlètes
imaginez qu'un athlète ou quelqu'un
d'autre soit contaminée avec ces
bactéries et qu'il a un système
immunologique femme et elle va croire
qu'il a une petite infection facile à
traiter
mais s'il s'avère que c'est une
infection sérieuse provoquée par une de
ces bactéries
il n'y aura pas d'antibiotiques pour le
soigner est-ce que vous déconseillé
d'aller à la plage à riom je suis né et
j'ai grandi ici j'adore la plage et j'ai
passé mon enfance à la plage du flamengo
mais je vais vous dire une chose
depuis huit ans je ne me baigne plus je
vais à la plage mais je ne rentre plus
dans la mer les bactéries retrouver dans
la baie sont résistantes aux
antibiotiques mais heureusement beaucoup
moins au sahel et au soleil leur
présence dans ces eaux montre malgré
tout l'ampleur des problèmes de voirie
et d'épuration des eaux usées à rio
la zone qui ne connaît que trop bien
cette situation c'est le nord de la
ville là bas d'immenses bidonvilles font
face à la baie de guanabara à leurs
pieds
la fameuse plage de ramos fait zhao est
un habitué
tous les week-ends il se rend en famille
au bord de mer aujourd'hui comme souvent
la plage est quasiment déserte
ici c'était la plage de ramos c'était un
grand succès dans les années 80 c'était
sensationnel
il y a énormément de travail ici
beaucoup de choses à faire pour sauver
la baie aujourd'hui c'est impossible de
se baigner
c'est très sale y'a quoi là dedans il ya
de tout ici c'est là mais de guanabara
il ya toutes sortes de pollutions à
l'aise à une plage de plus impropre à la
baignade
une plage où seul le sable et nettoyer
régulièrement comme pour cacher la
misère
alors juste derrière la plage la mairie
a créé il ya dix ans un lieu insolite la
piscine de ramos
un immense lagon salé artificielle de 26
mille mètres carrés le seul endroit où
les favelas dos des quartiers nord
peuvent encore se baigner l'eau de la
piscine vient de la baie de guanabara
elle rentre par là et là bas elle passe
par un système de filtrage avec du
chlore
cette machine est ensuite elle est
rejetée dans le bassin à la veille
aoka la salle l'eau arrive par ces
canalisations et il y à une valve pour
éviter qu'il n'y ait trop de chlore dans
l'eau okal 30 millions de litres d'eau
de mer sont traités chaque jour avec
3000 litres de chlore la piscine de
ramos est censé avoir l'eau la plus
propre de rio mais plusieurs études ont
montré ces dernières années qu'elle
s'apparente plus en réalité à un
bouillon de culture
le nettoyage de la baie de guanabara ne
passera pas par des solutions gadgets
comme la piscine de ramos ou par des
mesures cosmétiques comme les échos
barrière
il faudra une vraie volonté politique
une politique honnête et durable dans la
situation politique actuelle du brésil
un espoir qui tient du miracle
[Musique]